it's been five years since former nfl
quarterback colin kaepernick played in a
professional football game now as you
know he hasn't been able to land a new
team since he began taking a knee during
the national anthem to protest police
brutality and racial injustice now he's
out with a new message for a younger
audience about not fitting in kaepernick
shares it in his new children's book i
color myself different jerika duncan
spoke with the books illustrator in an
exclusive interview you'll only see on
cbs mornings
when colin kaepernick took this stance
i'll continue to sit the quarterback was
labeled controversial and quickly found
himself in a league of his own but it
wasn't the first time kaepernick felt
left out
[Music]
that started with this collin and a
seemingly simple kindergarten assignment
draw your family
in this autobiographical book colin
remembers kids asking why are you the
only brown one in your family why did
you color yourself different
kaepernick who's biracial and adopted by
white parents drew them in yellow crown
and himself in brown
in the book i color myself different
kaepernick writes about adapting to
adoption at one point wondering if
adopted means different
to color himself in the book kaepernick
picked an artist he hadn't met who had
never even illustrated a children's book
before this is by far the most high
profile
job i've ever done eric wilkerson's work
had mostly been sci-fi and fantasy i
didn't get the little boy learns how to
tie his shoes by some random author they
threw me right in and gave me my first
children's book being a
celebrity
book so that was
a big deal wilkerson who isn't a
football fan hadn't even heard of
kaepernick until his kneeling made
national headlines the fact that they
took away the thing that he loved to do
most in life just for
standing up and
speaking out i just thought that was
really
horrible
every scene that he was in i wanted
there to be this
warm happy color around him during the
pandemic the pair huddled up over zoom
to discuss the drawings this is the
level of back and forth conversation
that happens
is that too
dramatic he was very involved he had
very specific ideas about colors and
how
he should look as a six-year-old boy it
is his story this is an event that
happened in his life
so he was involved in every stage of it
every page
and for wilkerson so was someone closer
to home this book from the start has
really been a love letter to my daughter
he drew kaepernick drawing inspiration
from his own biracial daughter leia who
was the same age as colin in the book i
basically told him my daughter has some
of the same characteristics some of the
same hair texture you're working with
this celebrity
and then you have an actual model that
you're able to you know live hey come
downstairs real quick let me
it just felt silly not to use my
daughter at the same time i'm playing
with my daughter i'm also composing
illustrations in my head wow can you
just stop real quick and i'll just
these photos of leia holding up a
newspaper became the cover
and colin on this first page began as
leia on their carpet this started out as
a photo i took of my daughter in our
kitchen just pretending to throw a
football when you first looked at this
book did you think to yourself hey he
kind of looks like me
you did yeah
leia got to meet the star quarterback
did you like talking to mr colin
kaepernick
what did he tell you keep on going
and do what you like to do a message
that she adopted from the book
ever since mom wrapped me in that warm
hug i knew having brown skin and being
adopted made me
special what do you want people to take
away from this book
our differences are what make us special
it's not something to be feared it's not
something to be hated if you can embrace
your own magnificence
then you can live a really positive
happy life
[Music]
well being different obviously takes
courage the goal for these children is
to walk away feeling good about what
makes them stand out my daughter loved
the book and as you guys know this is
not just uh something that he's done
outside of football colin kaepernick had
the netflix special
and also was leading a non-profit
although i know you know he's been uh
possibly looking at entertaining going
back into the league he's still working
out
oh the book is beautiful it is bravo
eric bravo little leia it's fantastic
the message of the book i love i love my
brown skin i love my family i love being
different and adoption makes me special
it's it's really really a great read
really good
maybe colin will sign it for him no i
got eric to sign mine i would like that
too i'd like to come in colin